[Música]
el presidente chileno Gabriel Boris
cumplió su primer año al frente del país
en medio de su segundo cambio
ministerial una derrota legislativa y un
leve aumento en su índice de aprobación
en Perú familiares de las víctimas
mortales de las protestas que han
sacudido al país salieron nuevamente a
las calles para pedir justicia por sus
seres queridos desde que se produjo la
primera muerte Los Fiscales han abierto
11 investigaciones
el clima vuelve a ser de las suyas en
distintas partes del mundo en Estados
Unidos en el estado de California padece
inundaciones en Perú hay emergencia en
siete regiones a causa del ciclón y
Argentina vive una ola de calor con
temperaturas récord hacemos un repaso
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Chile el presidente de izquierdas
Gabriel borich celebró este sábado su
primer año de mandato Este primer
aniversario coincide con una
reestructuración de su gabinete de
ministros y con el rechazo del Congreso
a su reforma fiscal pero también Está
marcado por una leve subida de la
popularidad del mandatario en los
sondeos de opinión el 11 de marzo de
2022 el presidente Gabriel borich asumió
el poder en Chile abriendo una etapa
inédita la de un mandato de cuatro años
otorgado al jefe de estado más joven de
la historia del país
Un año más tarde el balance de su
gestión se ve marcado por la baja
popularidad y una serie de tropiezos en
la semana previa la celebración del
primer año de gobierno el mandatario
sufrió un revés la cámara de diputados
rechazó su proyecto de reforma fiscal
pieza central del programa de su
gobierno preveía Un aumento progresivo
de los impuestos para los sectores más
ricos del país con el fin de financiar
nuevos derechos sociales en educación
pensiones y salud esta fue la segunda
derrota del ejecutivo chileno la primera
ocurrió el 4 de septiembre de 2022
cuando el 62% de los votantes rechazó el
proyecto de una nueva constitución el
golpe que le significó al plebiscito del
4 de septiembre sin duda tan valió
muchísimo al gobierno ha sido un
terremoto que le ha afectado tanto desde
el punto de vista de su proyecto
político que quería instalar en Chile
pero también respecto de quiénes eran
las autoridades quienes eran los voceros
que Ellos tenían al interior del
gobierno otra crisis para el gobierno
fue la del conflicto mapuche en el sur
del país donde la población indígena
reclama desde hace años la devolución de
las tierras ancestrales si bien el
presidente había criticado la
militarización de la zona por parte del
gobierno anterior dio un giro de 180
grados al anunciar el regreso de los
militares pero a pesar de todos estos
contratiempos el primer aniversario de
su mandato coincide también con signos
de recuperación económica con una caída
de la inflación el control del desempleo
y un fortalecimiento del peso frente a
las Divisas extranjeras vamos a Perú en
juliaca los familiares de las víctimas
que murieron en las intensas protestas
antigubernamentales que empezaron en
enero en el país andino recuerdan a sus
seres queridos Y piden justicia la
fiscalía ya ha abierto 11
investigaciones el número de muertos
asciende a 49 Andrés granadillo tiene
los detalles
en esta casa hay un Barrio Pobre de
juliaca al sur de Perú asunta jumpiry
llora la muerte de su hijo Brian que
murió en las fuertes protestas del 9 de
enero contra la presidenta Dina boluarte
crees que vamos a perdonar eso a ella no
nosotros no vamos a perdonar yo en caso
temió no yo estoy dispuesta a luchar si
voy a morir sí por este Perú sí voy a
voy a luchar no tengo miedo ahora que mi
hijo se ha muerto yo ya no tengo miedo
para muerte ya las cámaras de seguridad
muestran el momento en que los
manifestantes estaban enfrentándose a la
policía y cuando Bryan fue alcanzado por
las balas el señor
fallecido Pero porque ayer estaba
moviéndose en vivo doctor porque yo
quería verla mijo porque no me has
dejado ver llorado la ciudad está llena
de Cicatrices las paredes y las ventanas
son testigos de lo que dejó el
levantamiento la gente Empezó a correr
porque había ese Este había bomba en la
ya estaban disparando a matar todo y la
gente era un loquerido todo el mundo ha
desaparecido en ese rato estrepitosa
salida del presidente izquierdista Pedro
Castillo
que intentó hacer un autogolpe de estado
al Ordenar el cierre del Congreso entre
otras medidas ocasionó que la gente se
volcara a las calles tras una misa en
memoria de las víctimas los familiares
claman justicia
mi hijo menor de edades de Seis añitos
tiene eso no Puede quitarme sobérate mi
hijo tenés que pagarme Yo quiero
justicia desde la primera Muerte en las
protestas que iniciaron A mediados de
diciembre la fiscalía ha abierto once
investigaciones a pesar de que las
muertes ascienden a 49
diversas partes del mundo sufren fuertes
embates naturales en el continente
americano tres naciones destacan por la
gravedad de los fenómenos que suceden en
gran parte por las consecuencias de la
crisis climática Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
emergencia climática en varias partes
del mundo Fuertes lluvias azotaron una
comunidad del Norte de California
Estados Unidos más de 1500 personas
fueron evacuadas debido al colapso de un
dique 50 estadounidenses fueron
rescatados este sábado estas lluvias
llegan después de intensas Nevadas que
también afectaron a los habitantes de
ese territorio más al sur Perú se ha
visto fuertemente afectado por los
embates del ciclo yaku el gobierno
declaró el estado de emergencia en siete
regiones cientos de familias han sido
desplazadas lo que se espera en Lima en
los próximos días de acuerdo a lo que ha
dicho la comunidad científica es de que
el ciclón conocido como yaku está
descendiendo de la zona norte y está
incrementando la temperatura en las
aguas y eso puede provocar lluvias
zona costera de Lima mientras en
Argentina se vive la peor ola de calor
en cinco décadas según el servicio
meteorológico nacional el país austral
registró además el segundo febrero más
Seco de su historia el promedio de
lluvias descendió a un 49% en realidad
el calor afecta a la gente Modesta gente
Modesta sufre el calor sufre el calor
hay deshidratación ahí sobre todo la
gente de pocos recursos y sobre todo los
niños hay muchos problemas de
deshidratación con los niños
especialistas del Centro Meteorológico
Nacional señalan a la crisis climática
como una de las causantes de estos
trastornos del tiempo tal fenómeno hace
que la probabilidad de ocurrencia de
olas de calor prolongadas aumenten en un
60%
que separa Estados Unidos de Canadá por
allí cruzaron 40.000 migrantes en 2022
una cifra récord tras haberse recorrido
el continente y las temperaturas no son
disuasorias en Canadá la solicitudes de
asilo se resuelve más rápido que en el
vecino país lo que resulta atractivo
para los migrantes
para muchas personas el sueño americano
está en Canadá como este grupo que trata
de entrar desde Estados Unidos por
roxanrote entre ellos Marcelo procedente
de Haití
siempre vi Canadá por televisión y quise
ir es un país muy bonito y me gustaría
conocerlo porque en Haití he sufrido
mucho y me gustaría tener una vida mejor
40.000 personas cruzaron en 2022 por
este punto una cifra récord tras pasar
por múltiples países en taxi hacen el
último tramo de su viaje
por lo general son 90 dólares por
familia una persona 70 dólares si son
más de una persona lo bajamos a 50
el invierno y Las bajas temperaturas de
la zona no son disuasorias las
organizaciones sociales les atienden en
la frontera
los niños son mucho más resistentes
simplemente no creo que se den cuenta de
lo que está pasando así que no es gran
cosa están jugando están hablando de la
nieve hacen lo que sea son los padres
que reaccionan más a veces de forma muy
emocional sobre todo cuando se preparan
para cruzar
ante el aumento de personas que llegan a
Canadá ha crecido el sentimiento
antimigrante hay peticiones de cerrar
roxanne ya tenemos muertos en nuestra
conciencia será roxanne claramente
significa tener más personas que
intentarán cruzar los campos en un país
donde el invierno es muy peligroso
muchos vienen tras un largo camino de
selvas desiertos y haber enfrentado los
peligros de las mafias como Carolina una
mujer colombiana solicitante de asilo y
que uno se topa con personas en México
que
piden dinero lo hacen bajar a uno del
bus y prácticamente los traumatizan
Canadá aprueba entre el 50 y el 60% de
las solicitudes de asilo lo hace en dos
años mucho menos tiempo que los cinco o
seis años que tarda Estados Unidos y
cerramos en Los Ángeles que última
detalles para la edición número 95 de
los Oscar en el teatro dolby la alfombra
roja ya se encuentra lista para recibir
a las estrellas más importantes de
Hollywood que llegarán para presenciar
los premios más importantes del cine en
distintas categorías este año de mejor
película compiten éxitos taquilleros
como Avatar el camino del agua Elvis la
película biográfica del Rey del rock and
roll y Top Gun la secuela del film que
se estrenó por primera vez en 1986
hasta aquí este Informativo en Flash 24
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]